all right Elena
Elena where are you from originally
where'd you grow up I was born in
Maryland and I grew up in Queens New
York
tell me about your family growing up
I was adopted uh as a baby
and I was adopted by a family of two
teachers and basically Queens is all I
knew so that's about it how would you
describe your childhood my childhood was
a little bit tumultuous I grew up with
um not a lot of stability as a kid my
brother had cancer when he was young so
I was shuffled around a lot while my
parents were trying to figure that out
my mom had a lot of problems after her
parents died so there were issues with
that and I also had a lot of issues on
my own front dealing with being adopted
I had a lot of
um
things that I had to work out being
adopted I never really felt like I
belonged anywhere I felt very abandoned
and I had abandoned Mission abandonment
issues throughout my childhood did you
find out that you were adopted early on
I knew I was adopted uh because my
brother was adopted also and he was a
week older than I was and my father used
to joke around that we were adopted to
people who would ask they they would
always ask if we were Twins and he made
jokes about us being adopted and in
hindsight they weren't very funny they
actually uh
traumatized me because it wasn't
something that I found funny uh he
didn't know that they were something
that were
trigger some to me he just thought that
he was clowning around and making a joke
about it but they were things that I
really struggled with especially since I
felt like my mom you know she she left
me in a hospital when I was first born
and I knew that growing up and I found
that him joking around about it was
really insensitive and every time people
were to ask about it I just felt like it
was a constant reminder of the fact that
a woman who gave birth to me didn't
really want me
other than the adoption issue were there
any other rough spots in your childhood
or that was the big issue
that was the big issue and then when my
brother got cancer I was abandoned a
second time because my father took care
of him and my mother couldn't handle it
so she stayed home by herself and nobody
really wanted to take care of me
so my grandparents took care of me for a
little while and then they decided that
they didn't want me either and then my
uncle took me in for a little while and
then I became too much for him and then
I was just sort of pawned off on family
members and I was abandoned for a second
time and it just always felt like I
didn't really have stability in those
formative years where you know a child
really needs stability and not to feel
like they're abandoned what were you
like in high school
high school was really rough for me my
dad actually taught in my high school
which wasn't good I think I needed my
own space to grow as a person and not
have somebody constantly down my throat
and making sure I was where I was
supposed to be I don't think I was able
to be my true self I think it was just I
was forced to be who he wanted me to be
and I think that
ultimately played a big part in
a really bad
um
youth experience you know Young
15 16 years old I rebelled a lot and
ultimately it led to me running away
you ran away at what age
I ran away as soon as I graduated high
school I ran away
I think I was 16 years old
Maryland or you went
uh well I was in New York at the time I
left New York I moved to Buffalo and
then I moved to Canada for a little
while and then ultimately I moved down
to Florida and I had no contact with my
family I wanted nothing to do with them
and then we reconnected when I ended up
getting pregnant at 20 years old
you have a child yes my child now is uh
12 years old and you're raising yeah I'm
a full-time single mom my son's never
met his dad hmm
and you live where now right now I live
in Queens there was domestic violence
issues with my son's dad
um
so I just decided it would be best for
me to raise him on my own I don't speak
to him I haven't spoken to him since
before my son was born it's better that
way he's basically a deadbeat I want
nothing to do with him and at the end of
the day he lost out on the best kid ever
my son and I are best friends and uh I'm
just so happy that I get to parent the
most amazing kid ever that's great
and how old are you now right now I just
turned 34. and how have you supported
yourself since you went on your own so I
graduated nursing in 2015 and I was a
stripper in the past and I did Sugar
babying also why'd you leave nursing uh
I left nursing because of covid and I
actually suffer from Ms so it's not
actually the safest profession for me
considering I have an autoimmune disease
so it's not really the best thing for me
to do health-wise
um so and how are you supporting
yourself today uh sugar baby sugar baby
it's interesting yes and so plastic
surgery is a big part of your life yes
obviously what how did that start
um it started out actually when I was
16.
um or maybe even before that I always
had this idea that
the only reason that
a mother would give up a child is
because they don't like the way they
look and this was my idea since I was a
very young child and I didn't really
know any better I knew that my
biological mother kept
two other daughters and gave me up so I
really only thought that the reason that
she gave me up was because of my looks
so I felt as though she didn't like what
I look like so I wanted to transform
what I look like to you know something
else to win love back
yeah to win my mother's love back
and uh basically I had my first
rhinoplasty at 16 years old and it was
an instant gratification for me I was
instantly happy with the way my nose
looked and then after that I basically
just wanted more and more I got my lips
done my cheeks done my chin done I had
gotten everything done to my face and I
just loved the way that I looked and it
was just such a different look and I
felt like I was so proud of this new me
and I ended up uh reconnecting with my
mom back in 2021 how'd that go uh she
told me that I looked beautiful and she
actually regretted giving me up for
adoption so I told her about all the
plastic surgery and uh she told me that
I I showed her before pictures and she
said that before I had my plastic
surgery that I looked most like her out
of all of her other daughters which was
very interesting to me and she still
told me that I looked beautiful did she
tell you why she gave you up she told me
that she gave me up because she had two
other daughters and she couldn't afford
them but the thing is after she gave me
up she had another daughter nine months
later after me basically so it really
didn't sit right with me and she said
she kept that fourth one yeah she kept
the fourth one and me and and the fourth
one Kim are actually the closest to this
day I love my little sister Kim and so
if anything came from it you know Kim
and I are very close and I love my
little sister Kim we talk almost all the
time
um
it's going to be hard for you to process
being the one
daughter that was
was not chosen was not kept yeah it was
really it was really hard whether you
can intellectually rationalize it or not
you were still of your of your three
sisters or of the four of the four
daughters you were you were
you were kicked out yeah
that's got to be difficult
yeah so back to your plastic surgery
what what other things have you had done
um
I had pretty much everything that you
could have on your face done
um I have instead of lip fillers I have
silicone uh in my lips so it's permanent
because I was spending so much money on
lip fillers that it was just
astronomical so I just got permanent uh
silicone uh basically fillers like
droplet fillers
um and then I got breast augmentation
three different times I have 800 CC's I
had a tummy tuck with
um basically a stomach corseting where
they sewed my stomach muscles shut I
have
um I had four bbls I have butt implants
what is a vbl uh it's
um basically Brazilian butt lift it's
where they do lipo 360 where they lipo
your whole body and they lipoed my arms
my legs basically everywhere and they
put the fat in my hips and in my butt
and I didn't feel that the fat was
enough so I I basically got silicone hip
implants and silicone butt implants and
uh what else did I do I did pretty much
everything
I'm sure I'm forgetting things I have
chinam I have a silicone chin implant I
talked about rhinoplasty so the idea is
to have more of an hourglass figure yes
yeah yeah is this an addiction for you
um it's not really an addiction it's
just something that I I want to look
perfect
and it's something that like people go
to the gym I go to the gym and stuff and
you always want to look better it's just
a maintenance type of thing do you think
it's just some sort of
um
thing you're doing to to you we
mentioned it earlier to gain the love
back of your mom or something along
those lines initially it was and then
when I realized my mother loves me it's
sort of it it stopped for a little while
like I was able to ease up on it and
um now I don't do it as often
um
I still feel as though I I want to look
perfect for myself
and I just want to feel like I'm the
best that I can be and it's not for
anybody else like I'm not doing this to
impress so and so I don't have a
boyfriend I don't have anything like
that I'm doing it because it makes me
happy and I think that we should all do
things that make us happy it's not
hurting me it's not hurting anybody else
I think it's just like you know guys who
go to the gym they're not going to the
gym because it's hurting anybody because
it's making somebody else happy it's
just because it's making themselves
happy and I think that we could all
stand to do things that you know for our
own mental health you know and this is
something that is good for my mental
health it's you know and my son supports
it I talk to him about it and
um I tell him you know it's really
important to you know work on your
mental health then do things that make
you happy and I tell them that this is
something that makes me happy and he
understands and we talk about like you
know positive things and things that
make us happy and his thing is video
games and my thing just happens to be
plastic surgery so you know I guess it's
a little bit different on a different
Spectrum but have you been in love
before
have I been in love Yeah I have been
and there are guys who are really into
the the look that you have right yeah
yeah for sure
[Music]
um
the guy that I was in love with is very
much into the look
um and uh it's kind of like you're
trying to be a Barbie doll or something
like that yeah yeah I love uh when when
people call me a Barbie doll it's like
the biggest compliment I could get I
love I love the Barbie doll look
um but but again I do it for myself this
is a girl as a young girl yes yes and uh
my whole house the inside like my area
not my son's room or anything like that
but my bedroom all the pillows are
Barbie the whole room was pink like it's
it's just my scene I just like it I
enjoy it and part of it like I I go to
therapy and I do analyze that aspect of
my myself and I think that maybe because
I had such a [__] childhood maybe I'm
reliving a little bit of my childhood
and maybe I'm going through that now and
you know Barbies are for little kids and
maybe I didn't get to experience that
some much as a little kid and maybe I'm
just going through that now and maybe I
just have to go through it deal with it
and you know maybe it'll be something
that I just love forever and maybe
that's just always going to be my thing
but maybe part of it what you're not
hurting anybody yeah I'm not hurting
anybody
to what you went through as a child yeah
yeah it's not hurting anybody I'm single
it's my room I could do what I want with
it but I love the Barbie look I love
pink and it is what it is what would you
say is your biggest fear what are you
most concerned about
um my biggest fear is
um something happening
to my son ultimately and him not
accepting
the whole Barbie thing and him saying
like I don't want you to do this anymore
because I love it so much and I think my
biggest fear is for him to say like
that's enough because if he does say
ultimately he's had it I will stop like
that's that's it like I I care about
what he thinks and his opinion matters
so much to me
um I'm a mother first before I'm a
Barbie before I'm a plastic surgery
Guru before anything and if he says he
doesn't want me to do any anymore that's
it and I think that's my biggest fear
that he tells me that he's had it with
my [__] how old is your son he's 12
going on 13 he'll be 13. that's right
that age where
that might come into play yeah but when
I asked him about it he loves it you
know he thinks it's actually really cool
as long as you're as long as you love
your son I think it all it'll all work
out yeah we we have like little mom son
dates I take him to get his hair dyed
and you know he loves doing that kind of
stuff and
again you're not hurting anybody yeah he
loves it
um he's he's very uh he's very much an
individual he likes he's very much into
style
um when there was a
and an exhibit at the Museum of Natural
History with fashion uh when that came
out we went to go see it together and he
loved it we took so many photos together
he's very much into fashion and you know
he's my little fashionista and I think
it's great you know because we could
relate to things on that level and I
think it's really cool that's really
great I I would have thought that
getting old might have been a big
concern of yours
no I'm not scared of getting old
um I embrace getting old but I'm gonna
do it with style
it's a great attitude yeah
do you have any regrets in your life
um
or if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done things
differently
I would have loved myself sooner
join the club yeah
that's a struggle for everybody yeah
most people yeah
and you have friends
um no
I don't have friends
um people don't understand me yeah I was
going to say are you misunderstood by
most people yeah I have my internet
friends you know the other girls who are
like me we're all in like a clique
together like we have you're friends
with Mary Magdalene yeah like I yeah we
have like a a little click you know
um Lacey wild a few other you know like
big plastic surgery people
um we're all in like this little like
click of you know plastic surgery do you
guys all get each other uh yeah yeah we
all get each other
um you know
um I have a friend Naomi I'm trying to
have a secret language yeah we all speak
a secret language we all have little
codes and we have forms of currency and
stuff like that and
no but I have a friend Naomi we just
went to Miami together and uh I went
with her to get her uh her boobs redone
so we all do stuff like that it's it's
definitely a different world because the
way we have fun is different than the
way other people have fun like people go
to Miami to go to the beach and stuff we
go to Miami to get boob jobs together so
what kind of guy is attracted to a woman
like you
um it's probably a certain type
guys with mommy issues yeah yeah
for sure
um and guys who
have issues at home with their wives
usually
and uh
that that's always an issue
being a sugar baby and doing things like
that what have you learned about men
that they're pinks
no offense yeah I've heard a lot yeah
you guys will be married oh yeah there
are a lot of married guys who will do
anything a lot of guys don't really
expect anything they just will pay you
for your time just companionship yeah
just companionship
they just want to be seen in public with
you yeah yeah a lot of guys just like
the look of having somebody you know
your own Community for sure yeah
so what's your dream what would you like
to be in five years ten years what do
you see uh settle down uh I think maybe
I the idea of being settled down is nice
but then again I like to have my own
space so maybe the idea of being settled
down but also having my own separate
house would be nice but sort of like the
best of both worlds for me like
my own house and then a house that we
could go to together and then a husband
with his own house that would be nice I
think that's why a lot of couples have
gigantic houses
yeah with lots of rooms lots of space
yeah yeah I think that would be it for
me so they can tolerate each other yeah
I think that would be perfect for me
and uh Elena what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
the most important lesson I've learned
is to not let the opinions of others
take away from
your values and take away from the way
that you feel about yourself because if
I were to sit and read through all the
comments on my videos on my posts about
every nasty thing that everybody has to
say too much yeah I would just be
sitting in my room crying all day you
have to avoid that yeah I I don't even
read comments because I really don't
care what Meredith from Montana has to
say about me and
another thing is
they're not living my life they don't
understand it they've never done this so
how can I expect them to understand what
I'm going through when they haven't done
this themselves they didn't get rejected
by a mom who kept her three other
daughters exactly they they've never
lived through this so how can they know
what I'm going through when they haven't
been through this themselves
they have no right to even comment on my
life when they haven't been through this
themselves and yeah they want to call me
ugly they want to and the biggest thing
that everybody says is
oh her lips are too much she was so much
prettier before I I don't care I like
them and you know what I really don't
care
um that's that's always the comment that
I get like I I couldn't even get past
anything I was too distracted by her
lips like
I think I think people need to
understand that
one this is a coping mechanism maybe for
what you went through as a as a young
girl
two you're not hurting anybody yeah you
don't look bad thank you really
beautiful thank you for certain guys
this is exactly what they love yeah so
it's like you have to you have to factor
in all that before you start making
judgments yeah
and probably for their husbands too and
that's probably some of the issues maybe
that's why they're not so positive a lot
of them are scared to do it themselves
and that's why they leave the negative
comments a lot of it's their own
insecurity what kind of emotions do you
go through
um
sometimes I get depressed
because I do remember the reasons that I
got here
but then
it's almost like a switch goes off and I
remember the conversations that I've had
with my biological mom and she has told
me that
you know I I love you and things like
that and just hearing that it makes it a
little bit better
but the depression really stems from the
fact that she didn't want to keep me
so the and and the bit about how she
kept my youngest sister you know and I'm
so happy that she did because I love my
youngest sister and I want to protect
her you know I know we didn't grow up
together but she's still my youngest
sister and I do I love Kim and I want to
protect her so much like if if I would
do anything for her and uh I'm glad she
didn't have to go through this you know
you've seen very good-hearted
considering that you were kind of
given the short stick yeah and
unfortunately I think
and I hate to say this
um
but unfortunately Karma might have
gotten the better of my biological
mother I have an older sister like I
told you
um Stacy
and she passed away
from terminal brain cancer so like I
said my biological assist my biological
sisters I had two of them that my mother
kept and only one of them made it past
27.
so
um
I think my my mom thinks about that too
and she was 27 when she died of brain
cancer and that really bothered me so
much because I finally got to meet them
and then I didn't get very long to spend
with them because my sister died
so do you have
sugar daddies that will
take care of you nicely oh yeah yeah
they do what kind of money do they spend
on you oh
um
it depends on what I need it depends on
what I ask for
um it's a
usually anything I ask for and you'll
have more than one at play at a time oh
yeah yeah I usually have a rotation and
yeah are those empty relationships for
you are they do you wish you had more of
a connection with anyone no I've had
somebody give me his 401k before
really yeah
so far I've spent on my plastic
surgeries a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars
um according to google at least I think
it's a little bit more
um and part of that was somebody who
gave me his 401k and one of the worst
things actually that somebody said to me
in a club was uh and I feel so guilty
repeating this but he said I wish I
didn't have my kids he was like I wish
my kids died so that I could give
um all my money to you
that's harsh yeah all right Elena thank
you so much for sharing your story all
right it was good to talk to you wish
you all the luck in the world thank you
thank you very much thank you